yo bootleg cat podcast man shout out to
Bravo the bag chase her new mixtape out
right now go watch our interview yes sir
let's just get right into it let's get
right to it come on
[Music]
all right
I need somebody I need somebody I need
some body don't know what y'all rabbit
don't know what the vibe is lately I
can't call it [__] really think that
this [__] a homebody I was hearing her
he ain't even nobody I was in my cell
couldn't talk to nobody heard my [__]
dying there hurt my whole body huh I'm
just being honest wish life was like
diamonds cause it might be so Flawless
imma hit a lick for a quick check why
you checking on a [__] boy you could
have been up when you straight down
[__] stay down free the whole gang on
that way now run the check up tank swing
like a playground my call my phone she
said she proud she say she happy on her
keep one in the dome [__] I stay hot
just know that I'm never alone
she gave me neck all in the vet say I
seen her favorite song just got attacked
and bought some new poles my young [__]
ready to go she say I'm the flight so I
stay in it here rapper slash trapping
[__] I stay in red make the wrong move
call this mama he dead he dead
yeah he did you heard what I said I'm
popping these pills I ain't taking no
meds [__] trying me and I'm back in
spread [__] okay
yeah let me hear that [__] real
quick yeah rival the back Chaser drop
one on you come on man
shout out to see I appreciate you guys
watching this freestyle we got another
one coming and then another one and then
another one and they're all brought to
you by our good Folks at LRG clothing
you already know what it is LRG been
keeping you fly for years they got so
much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle's on the way
presented by LRG